foreign
San Clemente California what's up Ashley
hey how are you good how are you
doing all right all right thank you
um
I'm wondering how
I can better connect with women after
being raised by a narcissistic letter
and now I have two boys and I'm in a new
community and just I'm finding it really
hard
to maintain friendships with women it
just seems as if it's not going anywhere
I'm just really happy go lucky and it
seems as if people are just getting
bored of me
and I can't keep friendships with people
why do you think that
give me some evidence that that's true
that people that you are happy go lucky
and they just get bored of you
and walk away
people seem happy to keep talking me
keeping up an acquaintances of sorts but
after a while of meeting up with our
kids and whatnot it just dies out
and it seems as if that's the case with
a lot of friendships that I have made
here so far and I start to think it's
not them it's me it's and I
I don't know that's fair that's fair
that's I mean that's that's fair
have you tried having people over in
your home
I have
it has it hasn't worked out tell me
about it
yeah it's it's worked out people are
really happy we have a huge start the
kids all the kids come over and
these are people
the kids enjoy it our kids play well
um you know I can keep a conversation
going I
we're having a good time but then it
just seems as if maybe they connect with
the other moms more or and they go off
and do their own thing at some point and
I'm just
waiting
to see if
they're going to call or they're going
to text or
yeah I I mean another example is I'm a
part of this support group at a farm for
parents and all the children are there
too and I do have a friend there and she
tried to be vulnerable with me and I
just I can't get myself to be
comfortable enough to say more than I'm
here for you I'm sorry you're going
through this that's really tough
and then she went on to express this her
situation at the support group and I
just watched all these women gather
around her and they're just saying
really honest and beautiful things that
things that I feel like I
had wanted to tell her but I just my
body just feels I know you talk about
this a lot just your body just
my body just really feels unsafe
yeah being vulnerable with people so
okay can I tell you you're right there
on the edge of this whole thing turning
around for you
what you just said is really powerful
hold on I want you to know how far you
come
you're talking years of counseling and
therapy to get to right where you said
right where you just articulated
the words are in your heart the words
are on your tongue you're ready to and
your body freezes up on you because when
you're a kid that level of vulnerability
got you hurt
right
yeah and my guess is there's probably
other romantic relationships that have
cycled through that as well Fair
foreign
not exactly because I you know I
I was the person to
leave people before I could be
vulnerable
with that that's what I mean as I'm
talking about the cycle like this whole
cycle period yeah so
all I have to say is this you're at a
precipice
and you get to choose what comes next
and
don't know how to do that
you gotta jump
I wish there was another way around it
the the the the the old DBT pathway is
there's a negative thought or a negative
trigger and it's all these women crowded
it's a friend of yours who's weeping
right and it automatically free freezes
your body up and maybe it's because when
Mama would start crying you knew oh God
here we go she's gonna drag me under
water and make me feel this way in that
way whatever
and that leads to negative emotions I
feel this thing and then I I act in
sometimes the negative action is don't
act sometimes just run and grab a drink
sometimes just go run and grab a a donut
sometimes it's freeze
I do nothing I let my friend just stand
out there in the cold
and then the fourth and I think this can
be the worst part of it all is the
negative emotions you internalize after
whatever action you do or don't do
yeah and then you beat yourself up about
it and the whole Loop starts over again
right yeah that's what this past two
weeks I've been like I just left
afterwards we're supposed to Coffee I
just left and packed my kids up and went
in the car and just thought I shouldn't
even
have friends like
I don't want to be I mean just this is
Extreme but you know I was just
reverting to my
child self and I just thought I don't
even want to be alive I just I don't
know why people need me their lives or
why I'm here or
and it's so extreme but
I just
felt that lonely child self come back
and hold force and and just started
blaming myself because I'm an adult now
when I have kids and just feels like I
shouldn't be doing this anymore right
but you don't have to run away but I am
and it just feels
immature and stupid and do you want to
be different
that listen listen hold on hold on
the way you're talking to yourself
that's your mom's words coming out of
your mouth at that seven-year-old little
girl stop
no don't let your mom keep talking into
your life
yeah okay
she didn't get a voice anymore
and I know that's easy to say in a short
phone call what this will mean is
several months
of you catching that voice every single
solitary time you hear it every time
I'm in the middle of this right now and
I'm telling you
it is the worst
every time I have a negative thought
negative self-talk and I am ruthless
with myself
um and I thought I could hide it on the
show and enough people called it out and
then sitting with the counselor like
it's bad it's not good
and catching it every single time and
challenging it what I'm telling you
already in my life is it's already
starting to fade
it's already starting to fade
here's what I want you to articulate for
me what is stopping you from reaching
out to her
and
saying hey
you had a moment of vulnerability
and I froze I'm so glad all those other
women were there but I want to Circle
back and check in with you how are you
doing now
what's stopping you from that that phone
call that conversation that cup of
coffee
because I I think you're I mean I think
you're that close to developing a deep
deep friendship with somebody
I mean I'm about to do that
um but you promise you'll do that for
the day's over
I will I'm just really scared of how
that conversation is going to go yes
afterwards
and if I'm going to be rejected or if
she's just going to play it off and say
like oh totally fine now do you think do
you think she even even noticed
that I left or that I didn't respond
my guess is she didn't even notice I
don't think she did
okay
when you are surrounded or raised or
worked for narcissist you you put your
head on a swivel 24 7 365 because you
never know where it's going to come from
we know bad guys are going to try to
hurt us and we know that uh fire will
burn us but when somebody who's
reportedly loves us
hurts us right it comes from it comes
from all angles and so
I oh you're so hyper aware I would bet
beyond anything
um
that she she certainly doesn't feel the
same way you do about it she's not
staying at home right now being like Oh
my gosh Ashley failed me she screwed up
so bad and then she just ran away I
almost guarantee you she's not doing
that
okay
and here's the thing a hundred percent
of relationships are a risk all of them
yeah I've been married for 20 years and
we dated five years before that
every day is a risk
starting a new friendship is a risk what
does that mean she could say yeah I'm
good man
are you gonna come over for coffee no
I'm good I don't want to hang out
and by the way if she says that she may
have diarrhea
it may not she may not be saying no
because she doesn't like you and you're
somewhere you know and so maybe the
second or third time she says no and
then
okay I get the message this hurts I'm
gonna be sad about it
and then I'm gonna go on
I and let me answer your question you
asked earlier I think you have the
opportunity to be such a powerful gift
to your kids and to other women in your
life
what you're hiding behind the garage
door is so uh important for people
so important
I'm not I'm not just making it up
because you've seen
people who are supposed to love you hurt
people
all of us have but most of us don't have
a vocabulary a language a relationship
to talk about that in you've got that
it's a gift you can share that
because so I just no don't guess so it
is it is
listen I um I'm terrified of heights
with all of my life
like for for my whole life I don't like
getting on ladders I don't like uh I
don't like I I just hate it I hate
heights
and then my buddy my boss
peer pressure just all into going
skydiving
and there's like no way I'm doing this
and then a couple of my colleagues
instantly said no I'm not doing it and I
was like well then for sure I'm doing it
then because I'm still middle schooler
when it comes to peer pressure and so I
went
and I got all and the guy who I was
Tethered to some big old tatted up smoke
show former Navy SEAL guy and he looked
at me said you're gonna try to fight me
as we go out the door we're going out
that door
the easier you want to make this the
better and then he said these words you
just gotta jump
and then I did
and I'll tell you it was Transcendent it
was it was uh just to not get too cheesy
as a spiritual moment the whole world
slowed down
right
yeah when it comes you were right there
you know your body's responding you know
how nervous you get you know how
comfortable you get
you gotta jump
and then when you go you gotta feel it
and I know you will but be cognizant of
it right this is a trigger for me it's
creating negative emotions which makes
me act a certain way or it doesn't make
me but it propels me into a different
kind of action and then I feel bad about
the way I just acted it just goes in a
circle on a circle in a circle and any
one of those points you can jump in
there and stop that cycle it's awesome
my body's feeling bad it shouldn't feel
that way yes it should it should my mom
sucked my mom was really not a great
person and and goofed me up from the
get-go now my body's doing what it
should be but I really want friends and
This Woman's hurting I'm gonna I'm gonna
lean in
that's how we go man we break that cycle
and we're gonna do it over and over and
over and over because that Cycle's super
entrenched and your kids are gonna get
to watch their mom
breathe for the first time in a long
time
I was talking to somebody the other day
who's struggling in their marriage and
they track all their sleep and
everything and she was telling me that
when her and her husband have been
reconnecting not sexually just
reconnecting just like hanging out
laughing talking uh telling story
whatever just reconnecting
um that all of our metrics are better
heart rate's a little bit slower
throughout the day sleep is a little bit
deeper throughout the evening it just
has a ripple effect through a person's
physiology
and so you're gonna you're gonna bring
peace to your home
when you just jump
you're worth friends my sister you're
worth friends and thank you for calling
let me know how this conversation goes
if you'll write me back in because
people are going to want to know how
this uh this coffee played out